to make your best shot
the problem here in the netherlands
is that we don't have enough
capacity
for in the hospitals for the people so
raise that up and i know it's not a
thing that can be erased in two or three
months but we don't do anything about it
so maybe we should solve that problem
and not
put everybody inside the houses make
them unhappy because unhappy people get
sick
i don't know what's it going to do to me
i had to
covet and
there wasn't not much problems for me
you know a little bit cold and a little
bit runny nose a little bit headache
and that's it you know
[Music]
so uh
for me uh i
i'm not scared you know for for this new
virus omnicron i'm
i'm not really scared for it i know some
people get really sick so uh it's not my
idea of to say if all you do you should
not get vaccinated it's your own
choice
[Music]
also have a company who sells pastry and
i have a hurricane
and it's for me very important that i
can open
because
i don't agree with the government right
now so
i want to be open for my guest to come
to me and to enjoy
and to have fun in life because all the
fun is away the fun is not here and
we want to have fun together be happy be
free
it's very important for me
[Music]
you